la justice merci la parole est à mme
sherman balanant
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et j'y
associe mon collègue bruno fuchs elle
s'appelait dinars elle avait 14 ans et
assumait son orientation sexuelle
victime de harcèlement scolaire
incessants pendant deux ans elle a
commis l'irréparable
cette tragédie nous crève le coeur et
nous exprimons nos condoléances à ses
proches monsieur le ministre
j'aurais aimé que ce soit ma première
question d'actualité dédié au
harcèlement scolaire c'est
malheureusement la troisième depuis
janvier dina est la dix neuvième victime
mortelle du harcèlement scolaire et ce
fléau sévit bien au delà de ces drames
irréversible les chiffres de la récente
mission du sénat sont édifiants 1
millions d'enfants et d'adolescents
verraient leurs conditions de vie et
d'apprentissage dégradé du fait de
l'harcèlement avec des conséquences de
long terme sur leur avenir et leur santé
vous mener une politique volontariste
face à ces violences l'expérimentation
clé en main était saluée unanimement par
les acteurs de l'enfance et sa
généralisation avec le programme phare
est prometteuse certaines mesures comme
l'instauration d' élèves ambassadeurs ou
d'équipés dédiées constituent des
progrès le travail des membres de la
communauté éducative et des associations
qui participent notamment à
l'accompagnement des victimes doit
également être reconnu toutefois pour
nos enfants pour l'école de la
république nous devons aller plus loin
et faire évoluer notre arsenal juridique
dès 2002 un délit spécifique de
harcèlement au travail a été créé en
reconnaissance des conditions
oppressante qu'un adulte peut subir dans
un environnement dans lequel ils passent
une part substantielle de son temps
aucun équivalent existe pour protéger
nos enfants pourtant bien plus
vulnérables en 2014 un délit général de
harcèlement moral a été instauré mais il
est inadapté inadapté au harcèlement
scolaire il ne permet pas de disposer de
données chiffrées est souvent écartée
dans les procédures nous devons monsieur
le ministre combler ce vide nous avons
déposé une proposition de loi en ce sens
quel sera votre propre aux îlots
position par dents sur ce texte
merci monsieur d'éviter la parole est à
monsieur jean michel blanquer
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
erwan balanant
je veux à mon tour est évidemment
exprimer l'émotion qui a été la mienne
et je pense tous les français vis-à-vis
de ce drame et de tout ce qui ressemble
à ces drames parce que le suicide
d'adolescents de façon générale qu'il
est le harcèlement comme cause ou
d'autres causes et est évidemment un
drame devant lequel on doit s'incliner
tout toute la lumière sera faite
d'ailleurs sur les cause par les
enquêtes qui sont en cours je veux aussi
vous remercier du travail que vous
faites sur ce sujet du rapport que vous
avez déjà rendu qui nous inspire déjà
pour les politiques publiques que vous
avez rappelé et merci d'avoir rappelé qu
en particulier en cette rentrée nous
assistons à la généralisation du
programme qu'on appelle le programme
phare qui est lui-même inspiré de ce qui
a le mieux marché à l'échelle mondiale
parce qu'il ya des pays qui ont réussi à
endiguer en bonne partie le harcèlement
même si c'est difficile de l'endiguer
totalement et ces pratiques là c'est les
élèves ambassadeurs c'est les
professeurs formés en formation initiale
comme en formation continue et c'est
toute une sensibilisation générale votre
question c'est aussi l'occasion de
sensibiliser tout le pays sur ce sujet
mes parents les familles la société
française en général parce que le
harcèlement scolaire doit cesser il
réunion réussi à ce qu'il cesse dans
certains établissements notamment en
réussissant ce qui est de l'engagement
positif des élèves une fraternité au
quotidien et c'est possible ce combat il
faut le mener à tous les niveaux
notamment un niveau pratique et pourquoi
pas un niveau législatif même si
évidemment sur le niveau législatif on a
déjà quelques outils comme ce que nous
avons mis dans la loi pour l'école de la
confiance quand nous avons parlé d'une
scolarité sans harcèlement scolaire je
suis évidemment ouvert à toutes les
propositions il n'y a aucune raison
d'être fermée à tout ce qui sera utile
pour permettre de diminuer le
harcèlement scolaire est donc bien
entendu j'étudierai de nouveau tout ce
que vous proposez en la matière et plus
généralement c'est un appel à la société
française pour en finir avec le
harcèlement scolaire ça commence avec ce
qui se dit en famille ce qui se dit dans
la scolarité pour ma part je mobilise
tout le système éducatif contre le
harcèlement scolaire merci monsieur le
ministre
[Applaudissements]